Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is what we have been waiting for.
Earlier, we talked about a neural network
that was able to describe in a full sentence
what we can see on an image.
And it had done a damn good job at that.
Then, we have talked about a technique that
did something really crazy, the exact opposite:
we wrote a sentence, and it created new images
according to that.
This is already incredible.
And we can create an algorithm like this by
training not one, but two neural networks:
The first is the generative network, that
creates millions of new images, and the discriminator
network judges whether these are real or fake
images.
The generative network can improve its game
based on the feedback and will create more
and more realistic looking images, while the
discriminator network gets better and better
at telling real images from fake ones.
Like humans, this rivalry drives both neural
networks towards perfecting their crafts.
This architecture is called a generative adversarial
network.
It is also like the classical, evergoing arms
race between criminals who create counterfeit
money and the government, which seeks to implement
newer and newer measures to tell a real hundred
dollar bill from a fake one.
The previous generative adversarial networks
were adept at creating new images, but due
to their limitations, their image outputs
were the size of a stamp at best.
And we were wondering, how long until we get
much higher resolution images from such a
system?
Well, I am delighted to say that apparently,
within the same year.
In this work, a two-stage version of this
architecture is proposed.
The stage 1 network is close to the generative
adversarial network we described.
And most of the fun happens in the stage 2
network, that takes this rough, low resolution
image and the text description and is told
to correct the defects of the previous output
and create a higher resolution version of
it.
In the video, the input text description and
the stage-1 results are shown, and building
on that, the higher resolution stage-2 images
are presented.
And the results are... unreal.
There was a previous article and Two Minute
Papers episode on the unreasonable effectiveness
of recurrent neural networks.
If that is unreasonable effectiveness, then
what is this?
The rate of progress in machine learning research
is unlike any other field I have ever seen.
I honestly can't believe what I am seeing
here.
Dear Fellow Scholars, what you see might very
well be history in the making.
Are there still faults in the results?
Of course there are.
Are they perfect?
No, they certainly aren't.
However, research is all about progress and
it's almost never possible to go from 0 to
a 100% with one new revolutionary idea.
However, I am sure that in 2017, researchers
will start working on generating full HD animations
with an improved version of this architecture.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, where
the ideas, challenges, and possible solutions
are very clearly presented.
And for now, I need some time to digest these
results.
Currently I feel like being dropped into the
middle of a science-fiction movie.
And, this one will be our last video for this
year.
We have had an amazing year with some incredible
growth on the channel, way more of you Fellow
Scholars decided to come with us on our journey
than I would have imagined.
Thank you so much for being a part of Two
Minute Papers, we'll be continuing full steam
ahead next year, and for now, I wish you a
Merry Christmas and happy holidays.
2016 was an amazing year for research, and
2017 will be even better.
Stay tuned!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!